[Applause]
all right here was more reaction she is
the co-host of the hit show The Five
look who's here
no introduction needed judge Jimmy
Carroll
thank you people may not know we've been
friends a lot we've been friends forever
too long
really no
um all right we've been friends a long
time people don't know that you're a
prosecutor we're going to hear from
dozens of Agents like this and stories
one after another I don't think we can
fix it with people like director Ray and
Merrick ARL in the news position well
there's no question we can't fix it I
mean never has the FBI in the history of
this country been held in such low
esteem and you're right I've been a
prosecutor a judge and a district
attorney I ran an office where we
prosecuted 40 000 cases a year okay the
bottom line here is that if the if the
FBI is not working on behalf of the
American people then they have to clean
house now we thought that after Comey
was fired that this new guy Christopher
Ray would come in and everything would
be cleaned up he would clean house
little did we know that he's just one of
the good old boys and even though they
lied and they manufactured evidence for
that buys a warrant so that they could a
spy on Donald Trump at the end of the
week 2016. they put their thumb on the
scale of that election they put their
thumb on the scale but not only did they
lied to a court as a judge you lie to me
you're going to jail all right they
didn't clean house struck McCabe a page
all of them there was no one who ever
gets fired in the FBI you can even lie
to them which everybody knows is an
automatic dismissal they'll keep you the
top of a fisa warrant says verified
James Comey signed three uh yeah three
fisa warrant applications with material
we now know was false and it was
unverified and he presented it to the
court he presented it again to re-up the
warrant to re-up the warrant and nothing
happens because this is the left this is
the Deep State this is a whole area of
our government and then you find out
they go in with guns blazing to a father
with seven kids to a former president's
house and Joe Biden gets to go to the
weekend house a few weeks in advance and
take care of everything and the worst
thing about Joe Biden I'm not even
talking about him as a president you
were a senator United States Senator you
have the gall to take classified
material out of a skiff and you leave
this stuff in a house 10 years later I
mean this is beyond the pillow by the
way one more thing I gotta talk let me
tell you
it's the FBI they should be on top of
the crime wave in this country they
should be worried about fentanyl they
should be worried about Crime Victims
but they're not they're worried about
domestic terrorists who are parents I've
got 30 seconds I want an answer on this
so the FBI weekly talked to Big tech
companies in 2020 what impact do you
think that had in them censoring the
very real Hunter Biden laptops I'll give
you two words election interference
that's what it was finger on the scale
election interference we love having you
anymore thank you I appreciate it all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else